Portugal literally got a digital nomad visa 2 weeks ago.
okay, this guy's video leaves out a lot of context.
I'm gonna explain,
so hopefully you better understand the situation.
portugal's population has been on decline for decades,
largely due to young people moving away.
Portugal needs more young people
the reason it's not down
even more is because they've had golden visas,
which allow older retirees to come in.
it would be lower without them,
but back on the visas.
for a second.
they've had a lot of visas.
but digital nomads have only been able to use 2 of them.
at best there are the D 2 and the D 7 visas.
the Entrepreneur and the Golden Investment visa.
if you will,
these pieces cost a lot of money
and a lot of investment.
most digital nomads cannot afford to do this.
for the Golden Bees,
you have to buy property,
invest hundreds of thousands of euros
for the entrepreneur
you have to invest 10,000 ish euros in a bank account
and then do a lot of hoop jumping.
the point being the people that are there
really want to be there a or have a lot of money
and in my experience
the foreigners that go to Portugal
have not really learned the language.
so I'll give creedence to not liking foreigners
generally. but there are good ones.
I know a few of them.
and if you as a foreigner
wanna go to Portugal
and you do not a speak it
or actively trying to learn it.
you're an embarrassment.
you get your shit together.
but back to the real issue at hand
of understanding this issue.
this is a NIMBY housing crisis issue.
regardless of immigration to Portugal,
even if they completely cut it,
there is a housing issue in Portugal
and there are nimby's in Portugal.
so while the government has recognized
they need young people to come in
because they have a negative population growth
they need to also in mass support development
of housing throughout the country
specifically in major cities
and while I'm all about hating on terrible expats
that don't respect your culture language
and aren't trying to actually integrate into society.
the vast majority are not the problem.
this is a regulation issue.
this is a investment issue by the country right now
and we need to fix it
because for years
they let the golden visa go unchecked
and it let hundreds of thousands of elderly people
move to your country and retire
and these people largely
add very little money to your economy
they only go there in like the summer to chill
so in my opinion
they should close and or limit the golden visas a lot
and mass mass support housing
and really push these digital nomad
and young people visas
because Portugal
is on a decline
population wise
and we need to get it on on board. okay.
and as someone who is going to move to Portugal.
I'm okay paying a higher tax,
a fee specifically
to offset these issues on local people
because a the first time I was there,
I lived on the Portuguese minimum wage.
so I'm aware of what it's like to live in Portugal
on the minimum wage.
but now I will be making a salary from the US there.
okay. I admit that all of that 100%.
and I know how much easy it will be for me
and I'm okay paying higher taxes
to help the welfare of my fellow Portuguese citizens.
a lot of people tag me and stuff,
thinking I'm being disingenuous
and not supportive these people
and I feel like all I do is constantly support
and think of solutions for this country.
I love Portugal
and I feel like
I'm a lot more well aware of the problems they face.
a lot of people
in my comments
who just say things,
please grow up, E Z.